auch darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
obersten kassen ärzte boss mit andreas
gassen der uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist
größer gassen und morgen hallo also wir
sehen da teilweise zustimmung aber ganz
genau sowas skepsis auf den straßen und
wird diskutieren hier im land also immer
noch mal über neue verschärfungen und
beschwerlichkeiten für den chor ohne
alltag während philipp hat das gerade
gesagt wenn dänemark hat einfach alles
frei ist und es eigentlich keine
begründung mehr gibt auch objektiv in
deutschland zu sagen das müssen wir
immer noch strenger handhaben also
finden sie noch eine begründung haben
sie noch eine erklärung für all diese
beschwerlichkeiten die es immer noch
gibt in unserem chor ohne eltern
gut also
es wird natürlich zunehmend schwieriger
dass das zu begründen also es gab ja
erklärt hat ja auch einige dinge gibt
die man hatte mir gesagt system darf ich
überlastet werden das ist ja sicher
richtig es war aber relativ früh klar
dass das nicht passieren wird dann haben
den impfquoten argumentiert wo man
gesagt hat wir brauchen eine quote von
80 85 prozent bei den erwachsenen zu
öffnen das hat sogar lauter wird sich
noch gesagt die haben wir jetzt dass wir
die nicht vorher wussten das kann ich
nicht beurteilen warum das akw diese
zahlen so verzögern herausgegeben hat im
grundsatz freue ich mich natürlich
darüber dass die kampagne bei den
kolleginnen kollegen den praxen zu
extrem erfolgreich waren wir so viele
menschen haben impfen können aber
natürlich muss man jetzt auch lange
überlegen wie kommt man geordnet aus der
pandemie raus und es geht ja nicht darum
morgen am tag alle vorsicht fahren zu
lassen sondern dass man einfach einen
zeitplan einen fahrplan entwickelt den
man natürlich mit gewissen bedingungen
sogar garnieren kann denn es macht
natürlich keine zu seinen sechs wochen
werden alle verpflichtet maßnahmen
aufgaben und wir haben in sechs uhr eine
situation wo tatsächlich intensivstation
voll werden also das wird ja jeder
vernünftige mensch nachvollziehen können
aber irgendwo brauchst glaube ich so
langsam mahlen plan
tja herr gassen also lka chef lothar
wieler hat jetzt seinen plan vorgestellt
und der lautet die maßnahmen gehen
weiter und seine begründung ist die
grippewelle also wenn grippe und corona
jetzt zusammenkommen einschlagen und die
intensivstationen belasten das könnte
unser gesundheitssystem doch gefährden
was sagen sie zu dieser argumentation
von händler
wenn er die finde ich schon schwierig
also ich meine natürlich die grippewelle
begegnen uns halt nun jedes jahr das ist
jetzt nicht wirklich überraschend dass
die im letzten jahr geringer ausgefallen
ist hat natürlich damit zu tun dass wir
alle wieder zu hause geblieben sind
insofern sich auch nicht mit grippe
anstecken konnten nun wurde ja immer
deutlicher vor ausgehoben dass die
grippe wesentlich weniger probleme
bereitet als als eine krone infektion
dass die objektiven daten zeigen
natürlich auch das corona gefährlicher
ist als eine grippe insofern finde ich
schwierig das jetzt miteinander zu
vermengen wir werden auch gegen die
grippe einer impfkampagne machen in den
praxen bei den kolleginnen und kollegen
und die werden wie in den letzten jahren
auch die zahl der menschen die sich
impfen lassen wollen problemlos meistern
das kriegen die praxen hier brauchen wir
keine apotheken und sonstige geschichten
für aber das ist ja keine neue situation
geimpft haben wir gegen grippe seit
jahren und bei uns wird das nicht im
jahr 20 21 machen und das jetzt war
bisher auch nie und so sagen wir müssen
jetzt restriktive maßnahmen das meist
eine grippewelle geben könnte
ähnliche instanzen ähnliche impfquote
was glauben sie wann machen wir es denn
endlich wie die dänen also wann kommt
für uns alle hier in deutschland auch
endlich das leben zurück wie wir es vor
zwei jahren kannten ja das ist eine gute
frage hat ich glaube am ende des tages
hat sich das thema krone im frühjahr
erledigt das sagen eigentlich auch alle
schon deshalb weil wer sich bis dahin
nicht impfen lassen wird wahrscheinlich
infektionen
erleben ob er davon etwas mitbekommen
ist die nächste frage aber dann wird
corona keine pandemie zu es in
deutschland mehr sein sondern es ist
eben eine endemische geschehen als ein
normales infektionsgeschehen bis dahin
aber alle maßnahmen auf das ist
sicherlich
übervorsichtig um es freundlich zu
formulieren wir haben ja mit dänemark
eigentlichen guten vergleich das ist ein
land mit einer vergleichbaren
ausstattung mit mit gesundheitsvorsorge
die haben eine impfquote dies ähnlich
und wir sehen ja dass die instanzen auch
da nicht durch die decke geschossen sind
und das ist ja auch nicht zu erwarten
denn wir haben eben bei so einer hohen
impfquoten natürlich auch viel weniger
menschen die sich wirklich mit corona
infizieren können dem tun das ja in der
regel nicht klinisch bemerkbar und von
daher ist allein dadurch schon die
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht so hoch dass
ich die inzidenz in extreme höhen
schrauben trotz der höheren anstieg bei
ansteckung durch delta
herr gassen ab heute sind tests nicht
mehr kostenlos das heißt dann für 3g
dass ich als ungeimpfte ich bin zwar
doppelt geimpft aber alle ungeimpften
müssten für tests extra bezahlen bevor
sie ins restaurant gehen können gerade
für ärmere menschen ist das natürlich
sehr sehr schwierig was sagen sie denn
dazu macht das medizinisch überhaupt
noch sinn oder könnte man jetzt einfach
sagen jeder hatte die chance sich impfen
zu lassen die meisten menschen sind
geimpft jetzt lassen wir es einfach
laufen und jeder macht wer will
also im grundsatz zu sagen dass man die
tests jetzt kostet licht macht kann man
durchaus gut begründet ist halt so jeder
hat einen gratis impfangebot das stets
monat zur verfügung das wird auch
weiterhin zur verfügung stehen die tests
waren ja immer sozusagen die krücke bis
zu einem ausreichenden impfangebot
sodass immer kommuniziert und die haben
mehrere milliarden gekostet man darf
eins braucht nicht völlig unterschätzen
die schlechte es waren ja nur noch in
der vergangenheit sehr oft in der kritik
qualität der durchführung seriosität der
anbieter also es ist jetzt nicht so dass
uns die schnelltests die bürger
schnelltest eine wirklich reale hohe
sicherheit gegeben aber es war besser
als gar nichts aber sicherlich wäre es
schlauer sich impfen zu lassen dass so
das was ich jedem erwachsenen raten
würde
auf der anderen seite haben sie
natürlich recht mit 2 gb was aus
medizinischer sicht natürlich eine
ideale konstellation ist wenn sie nur
geimpft und genießen in irgendwelchen
veranstaltung kann natürlich nach
menschlichem ermessen nichts passieren
3g ist dann etwas schlechter aber immer
noch eine höhere sicherheit als wenn sie
alles ausmachen aber letztendlich wäre
es natürlich die frage inwieweit das
über eine verpflichtung laufen muss oder
ob das nachher im rahmen der
individuellen entscheidungen zu
verordnen und man muss auch anerkennen
wenn private anbieter seines restaurants
kinos etc die entsteht ja völlig frei
für ihr
angebot eine 2 3 gegen regel auszurufen
das wird der 1 so oder andere anders
machen aber ich glaube das muss man
starrt mich nicht verordnen das sagte
andreas gassen kassenärzte chef vielen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
[Musik]